hi there Steve here again I want to do a
video here in English to cover some of
the ground that I covered in a recent
video which I did in French on the
subject of why link is a commercial site
and if you look in YouTube you'll see
the previous YouTube video put up by
this gentleman from France who said
essentially you know I've been listening
to Steve's videos where he talks he has
all these ideas about language learning
and encouraging people to learn
languages and then when I went to the
link I discovered that they're talking
about points of dollars and and all of a
sudden struck me that it was a
commercial site and I was quite shocked
and so what I said was that I can
understand that he found it to be very
commercial because it is commercial and
so I explained in the video that you
know add link we have programmers whom
we have to pay we have employees we have
costs we have servers and you know
significant costs and we have been at
this for five or six years and we think
we're starting to get there but we're
not yet at a point where we covered our
costs so yeah we do like people to pay
if they appreciate our service and I
don't think there should be anything
shocking about the fact that a service
or a product is offered for sale for
money and I very much and I mentioned as
before I find it extremely annoying this
idea on the internet that things just
should be free how can they possibly be
free either people are paid to do some
other job and then in their free time
they put up a site which is fine or they
do it as their main job or there are
people employed there and these people
expect to be paid because that's the way
our society works and you get paid at
one job and with that you go off
somewhere and of course in your job
you're producing a product or a sir
that other people considered the
consider to be valuable enough to pay
for so you earn your money and then you
go off and spend your money to buy a
shirt to buy a book or whatever you want
to buy that's how the system works
why would you expect that things should
be free and there is a sin somehow I
know I'm sure there are people who are
members of Lincoln we offer a lot of
things for free at link and for very
good reasons one reason is that all of
it of course our content is free er
audio and text is free and that's for
the very good reason that we receive it
free of charge so we can't possibly sell
something that we get for free the
second reason is that we offer a lot of
our functionality free you know up to a
limit of so many words and phrases is
that we're hoping this will encourage
more people to join the site so it's
basically a means of promoting the site
it's not because I want to spend a lot
of money hiring programmers and staff
and creating a system so that the world
can come to this trough and eat for free
you know I may want to do that but
obviously I could not continue doing
that for very long to me there's nothing
morally superior about free you know if
you know and that's not say that I'm
against public services but they are not
they're not free I pay taxes and there's
a there's an upfront transparent formula
which says that I'm required to pay so
much in taxes and I can see where the
government spends my money I'm often not
very happy about how they spend my money
but it's open it's clear and the some
facilities I really enjoy I go to the
local community center and I pay a very
small amount of money to use it to swim
to work out and I'm happy and that's
subsidized by my taxes and that's fine
and health and education and so forth
that's all fine and dandy but what I
object to is like now I go to I go to
Wikipedia and there's a big banner at
the
the founder of Wikipedia is begging for
a donation I wish you would stop doing
that
I find Wikipedia very useful if he said
to me it's $5 a year or $10 a year I
would gladly pay that amount of money if
he has and I'm sure he doesn't have many
millions of people visiting his site if
they all paid five or ten dollars then
he'd have all the money he needed what
what is this business about being free
and then begging now it you know because
that what bothers me is I know from my
research that when you have a begging
bowl at your website there isn't one
percent of visitors who contributes
ninety nine percent are happy to use it
free and so if you have a product or a
service like Wikipedia you should charge
for it and if people if say Wikipedia
starts to charge five or ten dollars a
year and people stop using it well then
that means that people don't value the
service I mean if I made lousy shoes and
gave them away people would take my
shoes but if I started charging you know
maybe ten dollars they would say they're
no good but the ten dollars they might
still take my shoes and at 50 to stop
taking them and so if your service is a
value in my opinion you should charge
for it now the other solution is to have
advertising I'm not a great fan of
advertising so we don't have advertising
at link I don't think we'd earn enough
from advertising we don't have enough
traffic but I also object to it every
time I open a language site and I see
rosetta stone and I see Confucius
Institute there I find it annoying so I
think what I think is a more reasonable
thing is to charge for the service now
there are aspects of marketing on the
internet the sort of longtail approach
that says that you provide a range of
services free of charge as a means of
attracting people and then a small
number will subscribe to sort of elite
services so that's a legitimate
marketing decision that's not altruism
so yeah you know what I and you know and
there are people like I know it at link
that there are a lot of people who like
using it free and who object to having
pay having to pay and they think they're
very clever because they can avoid
paying because they can delete words and
stay you know keep their database of
saved words and phrases below 300 but
they're defeating the purpose of the
system I mean I have in just Russian
alone I've saved thirty thousand words
and phrases I got ten thousand in
Portuguese and so when I open up new
content I immediately see which are my
new words which are my words that I'm
trying to learn there's tremendous
benefit from maintaining a full database
of all these words and phrases that
you're Avesta gonna learn why would you
I mean you're putting in a time you know
and these are not people who can't
afford ten dollars a month as is the
case with link or if we go back to
Wikipedia no the argument always would
be well you know Wikipedia wants to make
you know knowledge available to
everybody around the world you know some
people are poor like a bigger pardon
people who access Wikipedia on a
computer or have access to a computer so
that if they own a computer they can pay
$10 a year for the service of using
Wikipedia if they're using that computer
at a local community center or a library
then that institution should pay $10 a
year in order to provide Wikipedia to
the people who visit that library so the
issue of not being able to afford it and
making knowledge free doesn't make sense
I guess another argument might be that
Wikipedia is run on the basis of
volunteers well that's fine most of
those volunteers have someone else
putting food on their table for them or
they work at a job so they can moonlight
so to speak and volunteer which is fine
nothing wrong with volunteering but just
because you have a lot of volunteers
doesn't mean that you also can't charge
for the service I can't take of anything
more commercial right now than the
Olympic game that's about to take place
here in Vancouver there they own the
name Olympic they've shut down Greek
restaurants because they use the name of
all the athletes show up with their
their skis and the brand name of their
supplier is totally commercial but
there's 25,000 volunteers that are going
to help out because they want to
similarly at Linc we have volunteers who
help us in many ways who create content
but I have always tried at length to say
okay you give us content we will reward
you with points the points that we get
that we confiscate from people who don't
use up all their points we at Linc
the tutors we want them to be
confiscated get confiscated compensated
so you tutor your language you earn
points you can then sign up with a tutor
in the language that you're trying to
learn as much as possible compensate
people for their effort I think that's a
good idea but there's nothing wrong with
volunteering but what I don't agree with
is the idea first of all that things on
the internet should be free because that
doesn't make sense and second of all the
idea of begging on the Internet I'm very
much opposed to it there you have it I
don't didn't quite cover quite the same
ground but more or less the same as was
in the French video and that was for
Vera a very loyal a volunteer at link
thank you